now you guys to listen to the show all
the time you know that 90% of the time
98% of the time you pretty much are
stuck with me I'm the deal this is what
we do it's you and me talking about your
life and money but occasionally I run
into a friend and I think they got
something to say and I bring them on
because I know they got something to say
and then you're always thankful that I
do that so this is not a guest a guest
driven show but but occasionally we talk
somebody a world famous into coming on
today is no exception Mark Cuban is
joining us he's stopping by Nashville
today to do some other stuff and we
talked him into sitting down and spend a
little time with us welcome mark thanks
for having me Dave well congratulations
on a pretty successful season thank you
Mavs did well not well enough but we'll
take it yeah you got to a point but yeah
unless you're unless you're still in it
you're not exactly there's one winner 29
teams tied for last yeah that's how it
works well welcome to Nashville we
appreciate you swinging by now you and I
have had a lot in common we bounce back
and forth emails and tweets and things
over the years and we've talked about a
lot of different different subjects you
know what I want to start off with today
is you know there's two sides to this
whole money equation there's the income
side the outgo side and most of the time
I'm spending my time on the outgo side
I'm telling people hey you got to trim
this you got to amputate the tie Oh
freaking ball stuff you can't afford
absolutely that I'm the guy that's doing
that all the time but occasionally I tap
the brakes and I reach over and go you
got an income problem an income problem
you've had this unbelievable I've
watched you from afar and I've watched
you a little closer in the last few
years
unbelievable tenacious work ethic what
even even when you were a kid where's
that come from I have no idea I guess my
dad my dad did upholstery on cars and I
watched him get up at 6:00 7:00 in the
morning or go to work 7:30 in the
morning 6 days a week and lots of times
work half a day on Sunday and I think he
well I don't think I know he was very
clear that you aren't going to follow my
footsteps you are not going to do what I
do um and you're going to have to do
whatever it takes and work however hard
you have to to do better
and you know and I've since I've been a
kid I've just been relentless that's the
only way to put it now you have brothers
and sisters two younger brothers are
they wired like that too
no not at all they're not as driven no
not the same way at all they're
completely different yeah I mean I was
the work nerd at my house I was a kid
little kid I had to be in business I had
to have something going all the time
Paulie I mean it's always something what
was yours your first thing you did to
make money um first thing was selling
garbage bags door-to-door um I wanted
some basketball shoes and my dad
basically said those shoes work you know
that you have on your feet and when you
have a job you can get whatever you want
and um one of his poker buddies set me
up to sell garbage bags door-to-door too
so I can get some basketball shoes you
know Rachel and I just finished the book
smart money smart kids and we we talked
to families all the time that one things
you have to do regardless of your income
regardless of your socio-economic strata
you have to teach kids to work oh yeah I
mean with my kids you know their health
is number one my number one fear and
then just not being jerks is number two
I wanted seriously I want them to
appreciate and respect not just what it
takes to be successful but the effort
that other people put in as well that
you know nothing is given to you and
they're certainly not going to have
anything given to them you know there's
that Malcolm Gladwell talks about it in
the book outliers 10,000 hours of
practice exactly in thousand hours of
practice to be world-class at something
and and business is no different I
always tell people business is is a
sport and I've sat down with our players
you know upset with Dirk and Vince
Carter and others and said look you know
you play basketball for 48 minutes you
practice two three hours a day and have
days off to rest in business there are
no days off there are no minutes off
business is a sport where it's always
game time 24 by 7 by 365 by forever and
there's always somebody trying to beat
you and and the minute you let down your
guard you're out of business
absolutely now you and I were talking
during we were having lunch right before
we I jumped on the microphone and we
were talking about my youngest is
graduating from college and you and I
have both been maybe some of the loudest
mouths on the whole planet between the
two of us would be
we've been teaming from Dallas to
Nashville for a lot the stupidity this
student loan Christ
oh my god is horrible you know it's
people talk about bubbles and the
questions but are we in a tech bubble of
the stock market
no but are we in a college tuition
bubble absolutely and will that bubble
burst absolutely and you know typically
behind every bubble there's a lot of
easy money and companies taking
advantage of the easy money and
inflating their revenues and what
colleges are doing are no different you
know it's easy to borrow money on B to
go to school to get a student loan
because it's all guaranteed you know and
colleges are happy to take it and it's
easy to raise tuition because as long as
students can borrow as much as they need
why once you raise your tuition why once
you spend it on nonsense that a college
why wouldn't you build buildings you
don't need in hire administrators that
you have no use for because you know the
money keeps on coming in and not only is
that bubble going to burst and impact
colleges and universities but it's
having a significantly negative impact
on our economy right now kids can't
graduate from school and go you know
least new apartments or buy new homes or
buy new cars or go out and buy a new
suit instead they've got to just you
know pay back their student loans and
that's that's a huge strain on our
economy it's a big problem it's you know
prom
you and I are both voracious perpetual
learners because just if you don't if
you're not learning you're getting
killed exactly getting your head take so
immediately so knowledge is not a
problem we obviously believe in gotta
work yeah so what are you teaching your
kids about going to college um well my
kids are for seven to ten so I go but I
mean you're know you're thinking about
this what I try to teach them is that
you know you've got to learn how to
learn to me the most important part of
college
is you know are you learning how to
learn because luck learning is a
lifetime achievement you know something
you've got to continuously do and one of
the things that I'm trying to create
varied interests for them because I
don't care what they major in in college
as long as they learn and I want them to
start now being excited about learning I
mean literally I'm online looking to see
if there's any programming camps for my
four-year-old you know and trying to
convince my daughter she doesn't have to
take every dance class in America
you know they can learn some other
things and experience those very cool
very cool now regarding debt your your
advice on the best way to get rich
other than invent broadcast comm or
anything like that you're lucky yeah
when we come back from this we're gonna
head into a break when we come back I
wanna I want you to talk about debt
share perception of that consumer debt
and the what you would do because I
always think it's it's very smart for
people to listen to people who have one
with money and obviously with your
notoriety you you definitely one with
money there's any question about guy and
you know Shark Tank is a way you're
getting into look it into the through
into the a lot of these businesses with
some specialized yeah and so um we'll
talk about that a little bit when I come
back as well as some of the things
you're learning on Shark Tank so good
stop Mark Cuban is our guest this
half-hour and so hang out with us
America we're glad you're here
this is called if you didn't know the
Dave Ramsey show
you